and this idea of discipline obviously uh
I talk about discipline a lot and one of
the things you were talking about
earlier with regards to veterans and
people that have listened to your
lectures and it's the same thing with me
people that listen to this podcaster or
read the books and and one of the things
that I've noticed and I've talked about
and I've gotten a lot of positive
feedback on is you know when you're in
the military you have this discipline
and beyond that beyond the discipline
that's imposed on you you also have a
lot that you have to just hold the line
yourself I mean when you're in the
military sure you go through boot camp
where there's a drill instructor that
yelling and all that but once you're in
the military you're doing what you have
to do it's self discipline that you
learn that and you become self
discipline and what happens is guys get
out and that's that's gone and that
hurts them and the other thing that
hurts them is they don't know what their
mission is anymore and and my big thing
with people that I've been telling vets
now is find what your next mission is go
find whatever your next mission in I
don't care what it is but it has to be
something and I was listening to you
talk on something the other day and and
you were you were talking about how not
doing anything when people are not going
anywhere when they're when they're
failing when they're when they don't
have the drive it's because they're not
accepting responsibility for anything
and and so my way of saying that is like
you need a new mission you can't be
responsible for something and you need
to go and move towards some new mission
and and do you encounter people that or
you see people that's very problematic
in the civilian side as well where
people they just don't know what they're
doing yeah don't take responsibility for
anything that's a part of this nihilism
you know is that because first of all
you learn the truth is relevant relative
and that there's no real moral order and
you know that alleviates you of
responsibility and that's why that's
such an attractive message to people but
the problem is is that it kills you it
kills your soul so to speak because well
when we can talk about this technically
so you know there are systems
neurological systems that underlie your
experience of
negative emotion and there are
neurological systems that underlie your
experience of positive emotion and there
are separate systems they obviously
interact but they're separate systems so
but the positive emotion system well
there's two of them but one of them sort
of kicks in when you get something that
you want so you know you're hungry and
you eat and that feels good and so
that's kind of the simple one but
there's a more sophisticated one that I
think is even more active in people and
it's the one that tells you that you're
moving forward towards something
worthwhile and that's actually the one
that gives people that sense of a
meaningful engagement in their life on a
moment-to-moment basis so and and it's
also it's also something that doesn't
have to go away like if you're hungry
and you eat well that's good but it's
over and then you're on to the next
thing right it's not exactly sustaining
it's just necessary that's called
consume Ettore reward by the way this
other reward system is incentive reward
and the incentive reward system works on
dopamine this neurochemical dopamine
which is also the neuro chemical tracks
that opiates and cocaine and
amphetamines the drugs that people
really like to abuse alcohol often for
some people activate and so you might
say if you don't have enough meaning in
your life then you're more prone to
addiction and that's definitely the case
even with rats if you take a rat you put
him in a cage by himself and he has
nothing to do and then you give him
access to cocaine he'll get addicted to
the point where he won't do anything but
take cocaine but if you throw the rat
back in with a bunch of other rats and
he gets to do rat things then it's very
hard to get him addicted to cocaine and
so the purposeless rat is prone to
addiction well it's the same with human
beings now here is a corollary to that
which is really cool so the magnitude of
the reward you experience as you're
moving towards a goal is proportionate
to the importance of the goal so that
means the more important the goal you
pick the more possibility there is for
the kind of reward let's say it's really
a state of being that is life-affirming
and it is directly life-affirming in
that you know like if you're in a
football game and you're and it's an
important football game and maybe you
break a finger and you know normally
that's that's
problem it hurts and you're gonna stop
doing whatever you're doing but if
you're right in the middle of the game
then you'll be so amped up on this
reward system that its analgesic it
stops the pain it also suppresses
anxiety so if you have a purpose then
its analgesic it take some of the pain
out of life it's very positive in that
it motivates and energizes you and
focuses you and makes you able to
remember and pay attention and it quells
fear and so those things are all direct
and so then you might think well what's
the best possible goal well and that's
that's the purpose I would say of
religious training and philosophical
training it's like just what the hell
are you doing in the world you know when
I would say well that's actually fairly
easy - also - also lay out and this is
why nihilism is a much weaker
philosophical position than it might
appear to be it's like well there are
lots of terrible things happening in the
world if you're not I don't care if
you're a believer in a theater or a
cynic of the highest sort you listen to
a story like the one that you wrote read
at the beginning of the of this podcast
and no one says well in a hundred
thousand years who the hell cares so why
does it matter no one says that they
listen to that not if they're human they
listen to that story and they think
that's not good it's like that's right
that's not good it's not good you should
do something about that because it's
it's it it's it's self evidently not
good so you might say well at least you
can start your self organization by
improving those things around you that
are self evidently not good and that's
easy man anybody can do this you can sit
down for 10 minutes say well I'm going
to be honest with myself like that's a
horrible thing to do I'm going to be
honest with myself okay I'm probably
doing a dozen stupid things that I could
quit doing that are making my life less
more wretched and also the people around
me and so you think okay what are those
things and you know if you really want
to know you have to want to know and
you're gonna get a bunch of information
that you don't want to hear but you'll
know it's true and you already knew it
in some sense and then you can ask
yourself okay
that's sucks and it's miserable and it's
not very self affirming is there one of
those things I would I would be willing
to do something about that I would
actually do something about you know
that I could do something about that I
would do something about which is also
another horrible question because as
soon as you get an answer to that then
you have a responsibility right it's
like oh god I have to go do that and
it's something you don't want to do you
don't want to do it that's why you've
been avoiding it and so then it's right
in front of you and it's like it's some
little trivial horrible thing that
you're not gonna get a pat on the back
for no one's gonna give you an award for
it and and most people would just say
Jesus you should have done that a long
time ago you moron and but then you go
do it that's kind of humility I would
say and then you keep doing that and
it's like there's this injunction in the
New Testament against praying in public
you know and it's like virtue signaling
it's like you don't pray in public
because then you go out and you show
everybody just what a great believer you
are and how good you are it's like well
that's what you're doing you're not
trying to get your act together that's
something you do in private at home you
think okay what kind of moron am i and
what stupid things am i doing and then
what could I possibly do to get rid of
one of those a little bit now well
anybody can do that and that's
associated with these great evils you
know in this way that we've already
described it's like you're constraining
you're improving your character and
you're constraining the kinds of actions
and perceptions that you have that are
going to make you sick of life and work
against it because failure does that
that's the Kanes story it's like keep
screwing up man see what happens if you
think that isn't gonna make you bitter
and if that isn't gonna make you
vengeful and if that isn't gonna make
you work to hurt people around you or at
least not to help them which is the same
thing then you're just not paying
attention everyone knows that's true
so well that's responsibility right and
then so you take on this great task of
putting yourself together it gives you
life meaning and that also helps you be
brought just against the fact that
there's lots of suffering in life and
there's lots of m---eleven
it's like yeah true man absolutely it's
worse than you think even but you can do
more about it than you think and there's
nothing in it except good but you also
have to take responsibility so that's
the thing you got to decide if that's
what you're gonna do but you don't get
to whine about it if you don't because
you haven't tested it